In the optimization
problem, we assumed
the compatibility
scores were data
that we could input directly
into the optimization model.
But where do these
scores come from?
In the words of the founder--
Neil Clark Warren --opposites
attract, then they attack.
eHarmony's compatibility
match score
is based on similarity
between users' answers
to the questionnaire.
Let us attempt to
demonstrate an approach
to develop compatibility scores.
We utilize public data from
eHarmony containing features
for 275,000 users and
binary compatibility.
Feature names and
exact values are
masked to protect
users' privacy.
Correspondingly we won't be
able to directly interpret
which features are
important as we do not
know the identity
of these features.
We used logistic regression
on pairs of users' differences
to predict compatibility.
To reduce the size
of the problem,
we filtered the data to include
only users in the Boston area
who have compatibility scores
listed in the data set.
We computed absolute difference
in features for these 1,475
pairs and trained a
logistic regression model
on these differences.
Let us observe the results
of this experiment.
If we use a low threshold in
the logistic regression model,
we predict more false
positives but also get
more true positives.
For example, the
classification matrix
for threshold equal
to 0.2 is as follows.
Note that we found 1,030
pairs that are not compatible
and 92 pairs that are
compatible correctly.
Note that 92 out of 319--
which is 227 plus 92 --of these
were correctly identified.
That is, 29% percent of
the matches we recommend
would be successful, a very high
success rate for online dating.
Clearly, there is a
potential for using
many other analytic methods.
Specifically trees,
which are especially
useful for predicting
compatibility
if there are nonlinear
relationships
between variables.
Clustering is another
potential approach
with the idea of
segmenting the users.
Finally, text analytics
is yet another approach
with the idea of analyzing
the text of users' profiles.
Of course, many other
techniques are possible.
To give some intuition
of various features,
let us see how the
probability of a match
changes with the distance
between the two adults.
It is interesting to note
that the probability drops
with distance, and then
for a very long distance,
the probability increases again.
Also interesting
is this graph that
shows that if the attractiveness
is too high or too low,
the probability of a
successful match decreases.
Finally, if the difference in
height is too high or too low,
the probability of
the match also drops.
It seems the sweet spot
is a difference in height
between four and eight inches.